hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game between alpha 0 and
stockfish I don't know if you remember
the previous time deepmind released
those 10 games I named one of my videos
alpha 0 C mortal cooks 1 game as a
reference to our own limbs which tooks
one game in 1923 in Copenhagen and it
was a it was a very impressive victory
over stockfish such such mastery you
know of using the to twang if you
haven't seen that game I will put a link
to it in the description below so feel
free to check it out it's really really
awesome but regarding this game it's a
very short game when I say a very short
game actually mean 56 moves something
something around 56 55 moves but only
the first life 22 are really important
and I'll show you what I mean by this
so without further ado let's check out
this very nice game alpha opens with
Knight to f3 again goes for the reti
opening it seems like this rate the
opening is mostly encountered in the
nicer games Knight to f6 by stockfish we
have c4 let me just fix that
c5 so the symmetrical variation of the
English is on the board and light to c3
and E 6 we have G 3 alpha prepares to
fianchetto the light square bishop and
now Queen to b6 and there is only one
game in the database that features
disposition but that game continued
Bishop to g2 here alpha goes d3 and
already on move 5 we have a position
that was never before reached in
tournament practice it's ok d5 we have
Bishop 2 G 2 alpha 3 in Cairo to the
bishop Bishop to e7 C capture Sundy 5e
capture Sun d5 and now II for alpha
pushes the poor sorry it stopped which
pushes d4 now we have Knight to d5
Knight captures pawn captures and here
up stockfish castles so now if we look
at this position it seems that sawfish
pawn structure is somewhat better alphas
D pawns is doubled and well if stockfish
can get rid of the d5 pawn it will be it
will be very good for a storage but it's
very hard to imagine how he will do this
the
this bishop will always keep an eye on
the porn when such idea might be the
mood death was played in the game so
here alpha castled we have Bishop to g4
h3 Bishop captures Queen captures all
very nice and now here you would think
that okay black it's gonna go to 97 9 f6
will be a nice square for the knight
from f6 also the night can be attacking
this pawn maybe you can double rooks on
the D file and at some point win the
pawn but here actually stuff which one
for night two a6
most likely the idea is to put a light
on c7 and from c7 attack the d5 pawn and
here is where it really gets interesting
here alpha pushes h4 and okay Bishop to
d6 alpha pushes h5 we have Queen to d8
alpha pushes h6 and okay we have g6 rook
to e1 taking taking the the open e file
Knight the c7 now black is hoping to
create a target off of the d5 pawn
bishop to d2 and now comes a 5 alpha
prevents b5 by pushing a 4 we have b6
and now comes a rook to e2 here alpha is
hoping to double up on the e-file by
playing rook a to e1 so stockfish of
course confronts the rook on the open e
file we have route captors on the 8th
and here Knight captures on e8 if you
play Queen captures on e8 then you'd get
Queen to f6 going for this
checkmate by Queen g7 and if we play
Bishop to f8 this will not work but it
will not work because of a very nice
idea
Bishop to f4 you threatened the knight
and the Black has no time to move the
knight or to protect it if you move with
a protector let's say rook c8 brush up
to d5 and you can stop checkmate so here
what you would have to do after this
Queen to f6 you can't block with Bishop
to f8 you have to play Queen to f8 and
then rook e1 white would gain
white would take the open e file and now
if rook e8 simple row capture snide
captures and Queen d8 the the Queen now
infiltrates attacking the b6 pawn I have
night defense than Queen d7 Queen c6 and
it will be a much better position
right so after rook captures an e8 not
Queen captures but rather Knight
captures on e8 and here
rook to e1 alpha wins the open e file
and black has to make a move now so like
I said this is move 22 it's already the
head this is a that was the interesting
part of the game without actually
sacrificing any pawns and even with
doubling its D pawn alpha now well we
can say that black is in sort of a tube
swung as the Queen can't really go
anywhere
this entire diagonal is taken by the
pawn by the Queen by the bishop the
knight can't really activate if you go
Knight f6 then Bishop to g5 is coming if
you try Knight c7 then again from c7
this this were discovered by the pawn b5
is covered by the pawn so it's very hard
to see how black can even activate so
first rook to b8 and b5 is not really a
threat any time soon since that would
make the a5 phone a huge weakness b3 by
alpha tonight's the c7 now and the rook
to e2 rook to e8 the stock Fischer
simply has to wait and see what happens
we have King to f1 rook to b8 and now
Bishop to h3 a much better diagonal as
now the d5 pawn is not attacked twice
well the bishop is on d6 rook to e8 and
now rook to e4 this is a most peculiar
move by alpha and it's hard to imagine
what alpha wants to do with it but it's
interesting if stockfish actually
captures this pawn then after rook to e1
the knight is under attack and after you
move the knight you get
Queen to c6 attacking the be sex pawn
and this is might be what off I had in
mind you capture my d5 upon I'm gonna go
after your b6 pawn because now it's
impossible to protect it if rook to b8
then white winds up with a very sneaky
idea but feel free to pause the video
and find this sneaky idea I'll give you
a couple of seconds as it's really I
mean now that you know that there is a
sneaky idea perhaps you will just play
it but you know either way for those of
you who were able to find it
congratulations you have just found a
very nice sneaky idea off a head in mind
and for the
we just want to enjoy the show the
movies Bishop to d7 you take away the
Queen's protection of the bishop on d6
and now if you play Bishop to e7 just
moving the bishop you will get rush up
to F for this now wins as there's no way
to protect the night if you move the
Knights then you lose the rook and if
you don't move the bishop if you protect
the bishop let's say you go Queen to a
faith then you get Bishop to g5 and this
is really really crazy the idea is now
you want to win the Queen you want to
play Bishop to f6 the g7 attack the
Queen the Queen has nowhere to go so
here black could go something like 96
but after rook to e6 this is the move
that alpha had in mind it's really
really an insane move you can't go
Bishop to f6 immediately because you're
gonna lose the h6 pawn but now rook to
e6 will win the bishop on d6 you cannot
capture the rock if you capture it you
get Bishop checks King moves and now
after Queen captures here there's really
no defense against Queen to e5 whatever
black plays Queen e5 check is coming and
after this a white will checkmate black
so after Luke to e6 you could consider
moving the bishop with the bishop to c7
but then comes the Bishop to f6 a very
strong idea
and now after any move black makes for
example c4 you could make room for the
Queen still butter up to G summon is
coming and after we move the Queen now
comes the Queen to e4 and after Bishop
to d6 Bishop captures on d4 and now
after the Queen moves white will finally
win the bishop so a very sneaky idea by
alpha this rook to e4 but stockfish just
ignores alpha rook to b8 is played alpha
goes back with the rookie has to find
another plan to continue this game rook
to e8 and now brush up to c1 rook to b8
we have looked to e2 and now Bishop to
f8 we have rook to e5 now the pawn on d5
needs to be protected Bishop back to d6
look back to e1 and Bishop back to FA
stock fisheries are very happy with
repeating moves if alpha would continue
rook to e5 stockfish would simply repeat
Bishop to d6 and we would have a very
nice a draw by repetition but Bishop to
G 2 alpha defends the pawn on d5 this
way we have Busher back to d6 and now
butter to d2
look the c8 and now comes Bishop to f4
and this is very interesting if Bishop
captures Queen captures night after Sun
d5
this is not possible because now you
would simply go Queen e5 and there's no
way to prevent both threats either
Bishop captures or Queen g7 checkmate if
if Knight have sex the block then g4 is
coming and there's nothing you can do
about g5 so after Bishop to f4 we have
Queen to d7 G 4 and now the jeep for the
G 1 is already on g4 so even closer to
that whole idea Luke to e8 and now comes
Luke to e4 and here again if you play
rook captures then phone captures Sun
doubles alpha spawns now the position is
very nice but for capture screen
captures and after something like b5
captures captures you would get King to
g1 the king is in check Queen back to d7
has to protect the night and then comes
g5 and the white position is much better
here after the bishop gets activated
so after efore we have worked the d8
smoke free doesn't wanna trade rooks
Bishop to g5 now attacking the rook rook
e8 and now Queen to f6 alpha is
threatening checkmate on g7 so Bishop to
f8 only move that works Queen to c6 this
is a beautiful idea Queen has the
capture captures captures and now we
have push up to d6 f4 we have King to f8
black tries to activate the King but
offices not so quickly we have f5g
captures on f5 we have a pawn captures
on f5 and now comes a rout captures on
e4
you can't 95 is of course out of
question as you would simply bond or a
piece here after Bishop captures but
here rook captures on e4
we have Bishop captures on e4 not this
to create another another passport but
to make our f5 phone protected but
rather this and here we have Bishop to
e5
and now as stockfish wanted to play f6
himself alpha doesn't allow it
we have f6 here here if tracking e2 and
black pushes f6 it will be very hard for
white to make progress but here alpha
push
f 6 and now the H 7 porn which is on a
light square became a target and this is
huge in the endgame the king now cannot
enter the game and the help out but
rather has to keep an eye on the h7
point so Bishop to a5 we have 98 but the
df6 point isn't really a target simply
King to have 2 and now if you actually
capture that white will simply capture
capture and c7 you cannot stop promotion
so after King f2 we have brush up to c7
King to f3 and now push it back to b8 we
have Bishop to f4 and here stockfish
simply captured the bishop special
characters on f4 and after King captures
on f4
it was in this position that stop Fisher
resigned in the game but before we see
why stockfish resigned we first have to
see was there anything stock fish could
have done instead of capturing here for
example you could try something like
Bishop to c7 but then you simply capture
it Knight captures the king cannot enter
the game the King has to keep an eye on
the h7 pawn and White will slowly but
surely gets the d7 escorted the pawn and
the win the game on the other hand you
could have tried Knight to d6 comes with
an attack against the bishop here but it
doesn't matter you can actually capture
the night it doesn't matter that the
bishops are of opposite colors because
after king e4 yeah of course black can
just move the bishop back and forth -
you cannot enter here because the Bishop
and pawn create a wall but as you can
see there is a very clear path here and
the King will simply take this path come
here attack the bishop bishop has to
move pull the pawn so we can demonstrate
after black keeps repeating moves with
the bishop and the white king will come
all the way here pull the pawn and now
you have to give up the bishop and it's
a winning game so after Bishop to f4
stock we decided to capture alpha
captured and stuff is resigned
once such sequence we can show is let's
say Knight captures on f6 King e5
attacks the knight Knight goes back
doesn't allow the King to approach but
into d5
King h8 now we can if the King comes
into the game via a fade and Bishop
captures is winning but this way there's
really nothing to do if you check the
king the King can approach the d6 square
becomes available if you go King eh
it's simply wait only then does white
play Bishop to d7 and now it's winning
White has to move now the king can reach
the d6 square and after Knight moves c7
will be winning once again
so yeah but shop capture scheme captures
a nice win by alpha zero and like I said
the entire game is very interesting and
that whole rookie for idea but the first
22 moves are what what really impressed
me how alpha achieved such a beautiful
passive position for his opponent
without can you know without too great
of a concession material or
position-wise okay he did double his
pawns but nothing nothing too drastic
here so yeah I really enjoyed that and I
really hope you enjoyed that as well
sure a lot of useful links will be in
the description below
from deepmind you know today to the
academic paper and to do everything
basically it's a below in the
description below in every one of my
videos also check out the immortal jokes
one game by alpha the one I referenced
in the beginning of the video I would
like to thank last role of force Lukas
procs Matthew Logan Matthew Johnston and
Thor Christian Strom Carlsen for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usually
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content pretty sure I'm
gonna do some more alpha versus Rockford
games so I think y'all and I will see
you soon